so when people have these antagonistic
personality styles like narcissism
one of the things that they don't have
is a self-reflective capacity and
self-reflective capacity is
how to be able to think about how is my
behavior affecting other people
how how do my words affect other people
so you stop before you speak
right so you don't just start screaming
in the middle of a room or you don't
wake up someone up in the middle of the
night and start yelling at them there's
there's no self-reflective capacity so
as a result
there's very little ability and it's a
big piece of empathy to reflect on how
you
affect other people for a narcissistic
person
to be vulnerable enough to say ah you
know i'm i'm this i'm
i'm i have this wound or i have this
insecurity
that is very shame activating for them
they feel
all the shame who wants to feel shame so
it's better to walk around and say hey
i'm superman
and so then you get to keep all that at
bay a person who may be again
we're using this term you know
codependent a person who maybe that or
more have
more dependency needs as it were is a
person who again
who might almost be too self-effacing
too
willing to own up to things that you
know that to what the word i would use
is pathologize themselves
to view them as sort of the the person
with the problem
and the challenge becomes this is that
for people who may be traditionally
termed codependent
they have a real likelihood of engaging
in self-blame everything's their fault
when you make everything your fault it's
actually a luxurious position in a way
it's very very unhealthy very unhealthy
because it's not good for the person
and it makes them feel as though they're
a bad person i'm responsible i'm why
this person is doing this right
when i say luxurious what i mean by that
is this person who feels
so out of control in this relationship
can get some level of control saying if
this is my fault then i can fix it
right and so by taking away self-blame
from a person saying this is not your
fault in a way that's almost more
terrifying
because if it's not my fault and it's
their issue
and that can't be fixed now what the
heck am i supposed to do
what am i doing right so the bottom's
been taken out i still find it
fascinating that they can't see it seems
like
it just seems like one of those things
that i mean have you actually
seen many narcissists say i'm a
narcissist
so perhaps it's a good time to talk
about the forms of narcissism because
you know when i looked into this and
when i started going oh my god
um again it was like a lifeline i'd
watch a video of yours or something on
narcissism and i'd
feel like okay it's not real it's not
real so
maybe explaining what a narcissist is
and then
the types of narcissism because um you
know there's a very big difference the
way that a covert versus an overt
narcissist
appears now the damage is probably very
similar but the
um on the surface they're very different
and
um so the covert narcissist which is my
experience is
super challenging like very challenging
so
so what is a narcissist and then what
are the types of narcissists
so narcissistic or narcissism or
narcissistic personalities are
characterized by
inconsistent or generally absent empathy
entitlement grandiosity arrogance
superficiality egocentricity being very
selfish
chronically seeking validation and
admiration
a need for a lot of control over a
situation a hypersensitivity to
criticism
difficulty regulating emotion especially
when they're frustrated
or disappointed real challenges with
intimacy in a close relationship
they they're not their their ability to
have sort of the back and forth of a
relationship
is constrained by their need for
for their own needs to be met so in
other words they almost view other
people as conveniences
to meet their needs and they're not able
to sort of do the back and forth and
make the sacrifices
required by a relationship when they set
goals they tend to set goals in the
basis of what they think the world would
like
rather than what's meaningful to them
and their capacity for empathy is really
challenged because they're constantly
sort of monitoring their environment for
threats
that's narcissism okay the challenge
with narcissism is there's a lot of
subtypes of narcissism
and they don't all sort of look exactly
the same traditionally most of us think
of the grandiose what you're calling the
overt narcissist
and grandiose narcissism is it's sort of
the the sort of
big extroverted attention seeking look
at me
i'm so great i'm at the center of the
party i'm the coolest i'm the best
you know constantly looking for the
social media followers and likes and
that's that's that person another form
of narcissism and a lot of researchers
believe that overt or
grandiose narcissism and covert
narcissism aren't necessarily always two
separate people
but they're two faces of the same coin
covert narcissism is also called
vulnerable narcissism and it's
characterized by all the stuff
i talked about but the way it shows is
in a much more
passive aggressive victimized way
so instead of just being in your face
you know you're so stupid
it's more like oh god everything comes
so easy to you someone like me who
actually does the work nothing happens
for me
but you just show up and you get money
like ah must be so nice to live in your
little world
and so i'm like i think i was just
insulted but i think at the same time i
also feel sorry for you
so i'm not sure what to feel right now
and they're
masterful at that maybe not
intentionally so when people are with
covert narcissistic
people they're actually exhausted by the
passive aggression they wonder why
they ruin every party they're brought to
but they also feel sorry for them
and they often think of the covert
narcissist as being anxious or depressed
more than they think of them as being
narcissistic because they're not the
life of the party quite the opposite
they're kind of the sad
hang dog person in the corner of the
party who's angry at everybody
and always looks like they're on the
verge of getting into a bar fight that's
your covert narcissist
now the communal narcissist is a whole
different animal
the communal narcissist is the
narcissist who gets their supply
by ostensibly doing nice things for
other people
they give people money they do
charitable stuff
look at me i'm rescuing an elephant i'm
doing this i'm doing that
but they want to be admired for it and
they get their admiration by doing nice
things for other people and they get
angry at people
if they don't feel like they're getting
enough admiration for it
so everybody thinks they're a saint but
the people who maybe work with them
or are in relationships with them say oh
my gosh everyone's telling me i'm so
lucky because they're so
helpful but they're such a mean person
there are malignant narcissists who
almost feel psychopathic they're very
exploitative
they're very manipulative they can be um
very callous very cold um they almost
feel dangerous
uh they have all the stuff of the
grandiose narcissist but with a much
more
like machiavellian like they know how to
work a room they know how to work a
system
these are people who often get to the
top of organizations they're not quite
psychopaths which is sort of an
entirely different kind of a thing out
there but they almost have that feel
then there are the self-righteous
narcissists who are super moral
and they're like i they they almost feel
really loyal like they they'll they're
sort of almost feel right or die but
they're not really because everything's
about how moral and great they are and
there's a right way to do things and
there's a wrong way to do things and
they're very
contemptuous of other people they almost
feel sort of
snobby and they're very judgy and so
people find them like what is what is
this like this person is not very nice
so
you can see then that these subtypes
mean that
people will say but they rescue all
these elephants i'm like but they have
no empathy
i mean empathy for elephants is great
but you got to be empathic with everyone
not just people who are giving you
supply or notoriety
so at the core of it it ends up being is
there a core to all of these
that that that that insecurity the
insecurity
that has to be managed with all of this
grandiose grandiosity
entitlement things that protect them and
get them narcissistic supply
so it's as though there are little empty
balloons that need to be filled up all
the time
by people telling them that they're
great